as of now this guy is
a perfect encapsulation of the elite
liberal view and as such
he says very terrible things and one of
those
very terrible things you might think
it's trivial but i actually don't think
it is he wants to take away
your beef he does i know this sounds
like a bill gates conspiracy theory
bill gates wants to take away your
hamburger he does he just said that
he said that he wants to take away your
beef he said quote
i don't think the poorest 80 countries
will be eating synthetic beef
i do think all rich countries should
move
to 100 synthetic beef
so he's saying poor countries they're
not going to be able to afford synthetic
beef but rich countries can
meaning fake meat that's grown in a lab
somewhere
and not only can they do that but they
should do that why should they do that i
don't know
because bill gates while he's a sales
genius and was able to sell a lot of
computers in the 90s
is a moral idiot i mean there's he has
no
there's no reason to believe that bill
gates has any sort of sophisticated
understanding of philosophy ethics
morality
theology he's just sort of saying stuff
but because he's really
rich and full of himself he believes
that he
is capable of pontificating on these
sorts of subjects
that he knows nothing about why should
they move to synthetic beef well
because this i'm just guessing here
because you know it's bad to kill the
animals why is it bad to kill the
animals i don't they never seem to
explain that
and because you know the methane from
the cows
it's to cause global warming what's
global warming is that really going to
kill us all maybe when's it going to
kill us 12 years 18 months
is it going to kill us before global
cooling kills us in the 1970s is it
going to kill us before
the essentially moderate weather that's
happened since the late 1990s
is that gonna i don't know they never
explain it but it is gonna kill us
that's why we gotta switch
to synthetic beef and bill gates adds
quote
you can get used to the taste difference
and the claim is
they're gonna make it taste even better
over time oh good the fake meat's going
to taste better over time
and you can get used to it you can get
used to it
so do it you have to now
you'll notice he's using these terms
here you know they should do this they
should do that
but more than he uses those kinds of
terms
he uses the terms of inevitability he'll
say this will
happen this won't happen
because for bill gates like all
progressives
he believes that the he understands the
science of history the science of
politics
and it's going to move in his direction
and if you don't like that
well that's too bad oh you got your
little constitution your little
self-government
well too bad buddy because i know the
way the future is going to move
and it's going to take your hamburger
away and there's nothing you can do
about it
bill gates expresses the same view on
jobs and
energy you know the left wingers like
bill gates and other
liberal elites have decided that they're
going to take away jobs in the energy
sector
joe biden promised he wouldn't do it but
at other times he promised he would do
it
we all knew he was going to do it now
he's done it he's taken away jobs
in the fossil fuel industry for instance
so
bill gates was on a tv show he was asked
hey what do you say to the millions of
people who are losing their jobs in the
energy industry
bill gates has soft consolation for them
what happens
to the 2.8 million americans that are
working in the oil and gas industry
this is a 30-year transition and there's
lots of
clean jobs that can be
created in those same locations a total
number of jobs will actually
go up there may be some places there's
dislocation and so as we budget
we have to think about those affected
communities
as well as funding the innovation and
deployment
who the hell is we who is we as we
decide how we're gonna
take away millions of jobs and we decide
what was the we
bill does bill think he's speaking for
the american people of course not
the american people don't want to take
away millions of energy jobs
that's why joe biden had to lie to them
before the election and say i'm not
going to
go after fracking i'm not going to go
after fossil fuels and then what does he
do he immediately goes after them
which those of us who had been listening
for a while we all knew that
but the fact that he lied shows that's
not popular so who is we bill we
i think are these self-appointed
benevolent bettors the liberal elites
who are going to usher in the new age
and there's just
nothing you can do about it yes well
there's going to be some displacement
but well you know but it's a 30-year
transition
what 30-year transition i didn't sign up
for any 30-year transition
and i didn't appoint bill freaking gates
to utterly transform the american energy
sector over 30 years when did i vote for
that
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone wading through the wasteland of
youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]